it was always going to be hard keeping
India's population of 1.3 billion
indoors those who ventured out on the
first day of the national lockdown face
the consequences police in Mumbai were
seen conducting roadside checks and it
appeared those found flattering the
rules faced instant justice with battens
and punishing push-ups Prime Minister
Narendra Modi says India is at war today
the war that the country has waged
against coronavirus will need 21 days
but three weeks is a long time for
people like this young migrant worker
stranded afraid and unable to leave
Delhi for his home state of Bihar after
the government cancelled all bus and
train services the police will beat me
I'm afraid they'll beat me they aren't
even allowing us to sit anywhere others
decided to walk home migrant laborers
sunday started walking 80 kilometres
after his employer shut down operations
and company accommodation in the state
of Uttar Pradesh they are not allowing
us to stay there they told us to leave
because the virus is a big threat
migrant workers joined the growing
number of homeless and poor at food
shelters the caretaker of one Center in
New Delhi told Al Jazeera their supplies
will only last another two days people
here have been snatching the plates from
our hands there are so many people now
that were finding it difficult to
function and are running out of food and
rations for the millions of poor and
daily wage earners in India the threat
of hunger looms larger than that of the
virus I am NOT saying that the lockdown
is unnecessary I am NOT the public
health expert and if we are told that is
necessary I am willing to believe it
birds only if it is accompanied by mass
relief mesh
to help people through this time and
it's not just one going to be 21 days
for them it's going to be a long time
before they get their jobs back so far
only state governments have announced
financial and humanitarian assistance
for people affected
India's finance minister says the
central government is working on an
economic plan Prime Minister Modi has
again been on TV to stress the
importance of social distancing but
that's not the priority for millions of
people who are now jobless and don't
know where their next meal is coming
from
Elizabeth puranam al Jazeera New Delhi